ENHANCES UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE.
STRENGTHENS FOOD INITIATIVES AND
INCREASES FEDERAL MEDICAID
FUNDING TO THE STATES . JUST A
SHORT TIME AGO THE WHITE HOUSE
ANNOUNCED THAT THE PRESIDENT
TESTED NEGATIVE FOR COVID-19
AFTER COMING IN CONTACT WITH A
BAZILLION OFFICIAL WHO WAS
INFECTED.
LET’S BRING IN FORMAL WHITE
HOUSE PHYSICIAN DR. RONNY
JACKSON.
JON:
GIVEN WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
BRAZILIAN DELEGATION AND THE
PRESS SECRETARY, FROM BRAZIL’S
PRESIDENTIAL OFFICE, TESTING
POSITIVE FOR CORONAVIRUS.
WAS APPROPRIATE FOR PRESENT
TRUMP TO TAKE THE TEST.
DR. RONNY JACKSON:
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING
TO APPLY TO THE SAME RULES
EVERYBODY ELSE’S AND TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU, I DON’T THINK
IT WAS A CRITICAL INDICATION TO
FRAME TO DO THE TEST PRETTY WAS
MUCH LIKE THE SITUATION BUT I
WAS GETTING, AND THAT PHYSICAL
EXAM.
IN A NO INDICATION THAT TESTING
THERE COMES A POINT WHERE THE
NARRATIVE, IS ALL ABOUT THAT AND
YOU HAVE TO DO SOMETHING TO MOVE
ON WHENEVER IS NEXT.
AND ACTUALLY THEN YOU CAN PUT
INTO BEEN A PREACHER THIS WOULD
HAPPEN HERE.
I THINK THAT THEY LOOKED AT
WHERE THE PRESIDENT HELD WITH
THE REGARDING ARREST, I THINK
THAT THEY ALSO DECIDED, I THINK
THE PRESIDENT, A JUST AND HEY,
LET’S JUST DO THE TEST AND
PUTTING TO BED AND MOVE ON.
IT IS WORKING HARD.
I THINK THE PRESS AND IS IN THE
LEFT ARE REALLY SPINNING THIS
OUT AND I THINK, WE NEED TO MOVE
ON.
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THOSE
THINGS.
I’M GLAD HE’S GOT IT DONE AND
I’M GLAD IT IS NEGATIVE AND I
HOPE WE CAN MOVE ON NOW.
AND NOT MAKE POLITICAL CHAOS OUT
OF THIS.
JON:
WE JUST PUT UP ABOUT SOME OF THE
BULLET POINTS OF THE CONTENTS OF
THIS FAMILIES FIRST CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE ACT AND THEN THEY ARE
AGAIN.
IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE YOU THINK
SHOULD BE THE LEGISLATION.
REPORTER:
I CAN’T SEE WHICH AVENUE SCREEN
THERE.
BUT I THINK THE LEGISLATION IS
GOOD.
BASED ON WHAT I KNOW ABOUT IT.
WHAT IS RIGHT, I THINK THAT IS
PROBABLY STUFF IN THERE THAT
THERE WAS FORCED IN THERE.
JUSTIN AMERICAN HERE, SOMETIMES
THEY’RE USING A CRISIS LIKE THIS
FOR POLITICAL ADVANTAGE AND GET
THINGS INTO THE LEGISLATION.
AND THEY DON’T NECESSARILY
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
I HAVE TO LOOK AT EVERYTHING BUT
I THINK FROM WHAT I’VE HEARD,
THE TESTING, I THINK IT IS
PROBABLY APPROPRIATE, THAT THE
PRESIDENT, SIGNED OFF ON IT.
IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE.
JON:
THE PRESIDENT ALSO HAS DECLARED
A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
THEY WANT TO PLAY IT FOR YOU
NOW.
SOME OF THE REASONS HE SAID HE
DECIDED TO DO THAT.
LISTEN .
>> YESTERDAY I DECLARED A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY WHICH WAS A
BIG DEAL . AND OPENED UP AVENUES
THAT WE WOULD NEVER BE ABLE TO
OPEN UP WITHOUT IT.
WE WILL MAKE MORE THAN
$50 BILLION AVAILABLE TO US
IMMEDIATELY AND DENSE DISASTER
RELIEF ON THIS.
>> SUE AND I MEAN STRUCK BY HOW
MUCH LIFE IS CHANGING IN THIS
COUNTRY AS A RESULT OF THIS
VIRUS AND ALTHOUGH IT HAS KILLED
SOME PEOPLE, RELATIVELY SMALL
NUMBER AND PRIMARILY, ELDERLY
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE WHO AN UNDERLY
MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS, IN THE
MONTH OF OUR BE GOING TO LOOK
BACK ON THIS AND SAY, WE WENT
OVERBOARD ON THIS.
DO YOU THINK THAT DOCTOR JACKSON
OR ARE THESE SIMPLY PRUDENT
PRETTY.
DR. RONNY JACKSON:
WE JUST DON’T KNOW.
BUT I HOPE YOU’RE RIGHT.
I THINK WE WILL LOOK BACK ON
THIS AND SAFE WE WERE
OVERREACTED A LITTLE BIT.
AND THEN IT IS IT IS BETTER TO
BE SAFE THAN SORRY THOUGH.
I THINK THIS THING IS FUN FOR
POLITICAL REASON I THINK A LOT
OF PEOPLE HAVE REALLY GONE
OVERBOARD WITH IT JUST, AND
CREATED A LOT OF FEAR THE DOES
NOT NEED TO BE HERE.
I’M TALKING HERE, I THOUGHT ON
ST. PATRICK’S DAY, AND FOLKS
HERE FIND OUT ABOUT IT THERE OUT
THERE, AND THE ELDERLY PEOPLE,
PEOPLE ARE PROTECTING THEIR
GRANDPARENTS IN ELDERLY.
MAKING SURE THEY STAY HOME AND
NEITHER BRING GROCERIES TO THEM
AND DO THINGS LIKE THAT FOR THE
REST OF US THAT ARE YOUNG AND
OTHERWISE HEALTHY, WILL GETTING
OUT AND NOT LETTING THIS DESTROY
LIVES.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT
AND BE TOGETHER TO SOME EXTENT.
OR TAKE PRECAUTIONS AND WASH
YOUR HANDS AND USE HAND
SANITIZER OUT THERE AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE.
I THINK WE WILL LOOK BACK ON THE
STONE AND SAY THAT THIS WAS A
LITTLE BIT OVERBLOWN.
HOPEFULLY A LOT OVERBLOWN WILL
BE ABLE TO MOVE ON.
AND DO BETTER NEXT TIME.
IT.
JON:
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE STORE
SHELVES THAT HAVE BEEN CLEANED
OUT, THE ATHLETIC SEASONS
COMPETITIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
CANCELED PRETTY UNIVERSITIES
THAT ARE CANCELING CLASSES.
TO ME IT IS UNBELIEVABLE WHAT IS
HAPPENING AS A RULE RESULT OF
THE CORONAVIRUS . SPEECH OF IF
YOU LOOK AT THIS POTENTIALLY
GOING ON FOR WEEKS AND WEEKS, WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO TAKE A
REASONABLE APPROACH TO THIS.
DR. RONNY JACKSON:
WITHOUT A LITTLE BIT TOO FAR TOO
FAST FOR THE CANCELLATIONS.
IN THE THINGS OF THAT NATURE AND
THE PRESIDENT HAS WORKED REALLY
HARD AND GREAT PAINS TO PROTECT
THIS WE NEED TO TRUST HIM TO DO
THIS PRETTY.
JON:
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE SOCIETY,
THE DAUGHTER BE HELD RESPONSIBLE